call your crush and say i have feelings
for you oh god oh god i think my crush
has a boyfriend i don't know if i should
call her
go don't think about it i know
two one go do you have feelings for
someone right now i do do they know it's
complicated
no
i said what i said
hey how's it going okay so i'm just
calling
hey how's it going okay yeah that aside
whatever so
yeah
um i want to gobble a gobble on you
[Laughter]
she she bypassed the how you doing you
went straight to it i am mad at you live
your life girlfriend yeah she's the
wendy williams fan
hi how are you doing
how you doing that's what's being candid
to let you know that i have feelings for
you
[Music]
because you know they just put their
heart on a plate and they said please
don't crush it
please sir
can i have some more
that was happening
and we know like
odds are if you have to ask this way
it's not going to end well no this might
be a little weird but i don't care here
goes i have a big fat ass crush on you
are you are you messing with me
no
i feel like i have feelings for you too
and i'm excited for you to come down and
for us to
get to know each other better
[Laughter]
that's crazy because i've been trying to
[ __ ] you too
if a girl says she has a crush on you
and you just want to bang her don't do
it would you like to go on a date you
know let's do it let's go well you know
it's kind of funny because i actually
have been meaning to ask you on a date
really yeah is that something you want
to do yeah that sounds good
let's do that all right okay bye
call you crush and say i have feelings
for you
there's someone i could see you thinking
of them this dude that i'm was crushing
on recently he had a girlfriend and i
think that's the reason why he kind of
what
he was crushing on a guy who has a
girlfriend yeah they can be by
and think
hey
so
i just i don't know if it's the anything
that's like that
but
when someone has a crush on you remember
they're mad rude let them go straight to
the gay it's called to say that i had a
crush on you and i was catching feelings
um i think you're fantastic man but i
don't care the same feelings relief and
getting an answer from him uh yeah
definitely call your crush and say i
have feelings for you i can do that so
she's my sister's friend
hey joel yeah
i have something to tell you i feel like
he's about to get crushed is it just me
hey let's let's find out
i
have a crush on you
oh
okay
i have a crush on you too
let's get it boy
okay uh that's it bye
so the problem was
i didn't want to cross a boundary with
my sister
[ __ ] your sister then i mean not [ __ ]
literally just put her aside you know
what i mean and she don't matter you
know what i mean if y'all guys doing
what you're doing i want to have my
friends and you have my friends they're
not friends no more they [ __ ]
i could understand if you just keep
banging all of your sister's friends and
then you stop and then they stop being
friends because of you yeah i could
understand but then you're ruining all
her friendships
but if that's not the case she should be
supportive let's go
call your crush and say i have feelings
for you okay
sure i have a girlfriend actually
he's definitely not gonna answer he's in
the military
hey
hi quincy um what's going on to be
honest i have a fatty crush on you and
to be honest i got a fatty [ __ ] that's
what i saw i really thought
i really
what are the way they talk who talks
like that
the other girl said i got a fat ass yeah
no crush on you what no i got a fatty i
got a fatty i've heard girls that got a
fatty which means they got a fat ass and
i've heard a fatty tooth or or i've
heard of fatty tuna but i'm not
yeah fatty tuna we're talking about the
puss no we actually talk about fish
fatty [ __ ] no
but i've never heard some girl be like i
got fatty feelings for you that's it's
like it's like saying like um or imagine
someone saying i got a juicy crush on
you
yes no that's oh no
yeah that's exactly what i mean
it's kind of cringe i got a fatty oh
yeah i just wanted to let you know that
oh my gosh are you messing with me
no
unless you want me to ban that thing
with you then you're going no no no i
love that i love that
do you see your face
[Laughter]
i don't know why if i should go in my
head i'm like [ __ ] we in oh she she
went oh i hate going oh you call that i
hail uh hey i go
you know the japanese uh
come face oh i don't know yeah there's a
word for that in japanese i don't
remember all right sorry i don't watch
enough of that weird prime of yours no i
just i don't watch it
i just wanted to say something to you
you ready
i have the links for you
[Music]
you said you don't even know me yeah you
have feelings for me
i can't even lie i've been that dude
before i'll be cool i'll be weird i'm a
girl like a month and a half in i love
you i was like she texted it to me too i
was like girl you don't give a [ __ ]
about it with that [ __ ] you don't
even know me you don't even know me you
love me yeah but you know i was like
whatever i love you
hey
i don't know if you have a partner or
anything or like if you're in a
relationship right now but i just want
to let you know that i have feelings for
you
okay
uh and i do too
really i i do yes okay let's go bro
kitty now i gotta get a shout out to the
ladies and the guys today i think
they're batting maybe like ninety
percent nine for ten you know what i'm
saying like super impressive right
because i know everybody watching at
home has done this text or this call to
somebody and they've been shot down oh
my msn
in person
text messages i've got some of it
[ __ ] laminated on my wall rejection
text
you know
beautiful memories shout outs to you
that go out there my dark twisted
fantasy kanye west yes yes i got all of
that so i'm very impressed by this
success rate right now yeah do you like
me is it reciprocated yes i do
yes it's mutual for sure would you
consider dating me
right on the girl just before it went
it's like her it's like her soul and her
[ __ ] high five
she
i feel bad for my sister over here long
distance no
i mean he's real he's honest he's a real
one so whenever he comes back from the
stern maybe that's gonna be able to do a
thing that'll be a thing or maybe that
was just a way to reject her crazy high
fives all around let's go
i i mean i feel it too because i mean
he's all the way in louisiana and long
distance is not fun well we met in
college like everyone thought we were
dating but we were really just good
friends in school
yo
girl charming with the curls
so man
yeah
um
charmaine
yeah you already know what time it is yo
that's it
that's her the way he answered
charmaine
made me think of that pokemon song which
one
chameleon war tortoise mewtwo everything
aerodynamic night slow poke
sorry all right that wasn't yet right
yeah yeah
gotta catch em all pokemon that's a
remix yeah that's a remix charmedian
you wanna go on a date with me
absolutely
i had a feeling that you liked me but i
wasn't 100 sure but not likely for a
while who do you have feelings for right
now they
have a boyfriend
has she ever made any hints that she's
not happy with her relationship oh yeah
hey don't no no no no cut production
don't be out here be no home wrecker
don't we start no problems this cup
produces just like
content
[Laughter]
i just wanted to call and say that i
like you and
i
like hanging out with you and i think
you are a voice message oh i know she
gotta have like a whole [ __ ] proof of
it and [ __ ] yeah
she she's going back she's gonna press
nine instead of seven call
she's gonna press nine instead of seven
let's take that [ __ ]
really gorgeous so we'll have to talk
about this more when you are back in
town or i'll see you at work and we'll
talk about this
whoa
that work
at work
they ended with the cringe they're good
they're cut
you're good at work
everything enjoyed losing your job
everything was good everything was great
everything was so awkward everything was
great until the end you put that [ __ ] at
the end you you know what the hell you
was doing i work work
well i mean hey man if you don't value
your job then oh this is a great way to
go out and go out with a bang
or not not bang
not banking at all potentially probably
most likely
good lord
that was yeah that was that was the one
anyways all right well listen i'm just
happy i never had to do that what about
you guys what has been your success rate
tell us some good stories are you guys
either getting rejected or accepted when
you have confessed to your crush we want
to hear from you guys in the comments
below and if you liked today's video
make sure to leave a like and a comment
everybody that goes out there
you're the real one